(man)
Start it.
♪
♪ Zombie on the track
♪ Started from the bottom
now we're here ♪
now my whole team here ♪
♪ Started from the bottom
now we're here ♪
now the whole team here ♪
♪ Started from the bottom
now we're here ♪
now my whole team here ♪
♪ Started from the bottom
now we're here ♪
now the whole team here ♪
♪ I done kept it real
from the jump ♪
♪ Livin' at my mama's house
we'd argue every mornin' ♪
♪ I was tryin' to get it
on my own ♪
♪ Workin' all night
traffic on the way home ♪
♪ And my uncle callin' me
like "Where you at? ♪
♪ I gave you the keys
told you bring it right back" ♪
♪ I just think it's funny
how it goes ♪
♪ Now I'm on the road
half a million for a show ♪
♪ Started from the bottom
now we're here ♪
now my whole team here ♪
♪ Started from the bottom
now we're here ♪
now the whole team here ♪
♪ Start, started from the bottom
now we're here ♪
♪ Started from the bottom
now the whole team here ♪
now we're here... ♪
(woman)
Ma'am... Ma'am... Ma'am...
Ma'am!
You didn't sign the back
of the check.
Oh... I'm sorry.
Uh, you know,
I wasn't sure
if there was a special
teller I should go to
for checks that are
this large?
Ooh, 8K, unh!
You know how
she got it, dude?
This bitch right here
drew this illustration,
and a sexy-ass
new dating web site bought it
for $8,000!
"An alert from your bank"?
What?
No.
This illustration.
Hey, came from her heart.
Great-- so do you
want this in cash?
No, I want it
in my savings account.
For somebody who works
at the bank,
(silly voice)
♪ I thought you'd be
♪ more responsible
with money ♪
Ludacris.
I also have some business
with the bank.
I'd like to cash
these nickels,
and I'll have them
in quarters, please.
Thank you so much.